es posible que su médico le recomiende
realizarse una endarterectomía carotídea
en caso de que sus arterias carótidas
estén más estrechas o bloqueadas a causa
de la placa en su cuello se encuentran
dos vasos sanguíneos importantes
llamados arterias carótidas las cuales
llevan sangre rica en oxígeno desde su
corazón hasta su cerebro usted puede
sentir el pulso de la arteria carótida
en la parte lateral de su cuello los
depósitos de grasa llamados placas
ateroscleróticas se pueden acumular
dentro de la arteria carótida estas
placas pueden hacer que el pasaje de la
arteria sea más estrecho y también
pueden interferir con el flujo sanguíneo
hacia el cerebro este bloqueo o
estrechamiento se denomina estenosis si
el flujo sanguíneo al cerebro se bloquea
de forma temporal puede ocurrir un
accidente isquémico transitorio también
conocido como a it cuando el flujo
sanguíneo se obstruye por completo como
en el bloqueo de una arteria carótida
puede ocurrir un accidente
cerebrovascular antes del procedimiento
se colocará una vía intravenosa
usualmente una endarterectomía carotídea
se realiza bajo anestesia
lo cual lo dormirá durante todo el
procedimiento en este caso se insertará
un tubo respiratorio por la boca hasta
su tráquea para ayudarlo a respirar
durante la operación algunas veces la
endarterectomía carotídea se realiza con
anestesia local si se utiliza anestesia
local
usted se mantendrá despierto pero su
cuello estará adormecido es probable que
además reciba algún sedante
en el lado de su cuello junto a la
arteria bloqueada el cirujano hará una
incisión que puede ir desde la parte
posterior de su oreja hasta un punto más
arriba de la clavícula su cirujano
encontrará la arteria carótida y
temporalmente detendrá el flujo
sanguíneo a través de la misma
su cirujano abrirá la arteria y colocará
una derivación o bypass temporal para
que la sangre siga fluyendo hacia el
cerebro
y luego sus cirujanos retirará la placa
que se encuentra dentro de las paredes
arteriales
después de haber eliminado el bloqueo el
cirujano suturar a la arteria
generalmente colocando un parche para
ensanchar la arteria ligeramente el
parche puede estar hecho con parte de
alguna de sus venas o de un material
artificial tal como dacrón
finalmente su cirujano cerrará la
incisión con suturas o grapas y la
cubrirá con vendas usualmente se deja un
drenaje temporal en la herida
después de la operación se le llevará a
un área de recuperación donde el
personal controlará sus signos vitales y
su condición neurológica se le
administrarán medicamentos para el dolor
según sea necesario y pasará
gradualmente de una dieta líquida a una
sólida